[Music]
Heat. Heat.
All right. Hello. And let's open up the
doors to our Zoom room here on Daily
with Doc. Folks, if you would like to
join us live, go ahead and do so by
going to dailywithdoczoom.com.
My name is Becca Dukes and as the
hostess of this program, I am excited to
be able to bring to you information that
is empowering.
Empowering not only in life in general,
but empowering specifically in your
health, your wellness. And for those of
you who are looking for a passion and a
purpose to help others also in your
financial
uh profile for empowerment. So everybody
hello and welcome to daily with doc. So
excited again to be here with you. Now,
if you were invited by somebody
specific, please make sure that you get
back with them and ask them questions in
regards to what that you need to do in
order to choose a better health journey.
And if you are here live with us or even
out on YouTube, Rumble or Facebook, we
do have parts of my team, people within
my team, my amazing team who are
watching the chat so that if you have
questions, you can put post them there
and we will work on getting your
questions asked here on our live show.
If we do not get to your questions, then
please go to dailywithdoc.com,
which is the website and the group that
is sponsoring this program. Again,
that's a dailywithdoc.com
and you will find the place where you
can sign up for our email list and also
submit questions. Now,
this program is for educational purposes
only. It is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician. Nor are
the products designed to diagnose, treat
or cure any diseases. But folks, we have
one of the doctors or the doctor who has
been instrumental in suing the FDA that
requires us to say that nine or eight or
nine times and prevailed, which means he
won the lawsuits that he sued or went up
against them for and making sure that
specific nutrients were one added to
baby food. two
gave us the ability to say that this
specific nutrient is essential for
certain conditions. So, I'm excited that
we do have this young man here with us
um because he has many decades of young
years under his belt in a way that is
understandable. That just makes sense,
folks. He calls himself just a dumb farm
boy from Missouri, but when you can't
call anybody dumb that's working their
way through college in a pathology lab,
finding the underlying causes of a mass
die off from ultimately pollution.
And then
as I look back at how I was seven years
ago comp and then looking at that
research that he did, it just made sense
that I myself
had been polluting my body with
something that I thought one was tasty,
but two was supposed to be good for me
because I was on a keto diet. And keto
diet says you can eat this, this, this,
and this, and this. Well, folks, you've
got to be very, very mindful of what you
are putting in your bio body. And
there's dirty keto and there's clean
keto. And you want to go with clean
keto. And another thing about a keto
diet, folks, it has very little
nutrition in it. So, you better be
supplementing. Well, today's program we
are going to be talking about some kids
and what Dr. Wallik has re been
researching
because he's continually researching
has to do with some of those risk
factors that are being found in kids
that could lead to dementia. So, without
further ado, Dr. Wallik. Hello and
welcome to Daily with Doc.
>> Well, thank you and your team. Um, it's
so so wonderful always to be with you.
It's been a while since we've been doing
this live. So, thank you so much,
Rebecca.
>> Well, I'm so glad, Dr. Wallik, that you
were able to take a vacation, get some
rest, and now be back with us.
Man,
you are all always always always always
researching stuff. So, tell us about
what is on your mind and the research
that you've been doing most recently.
>> Okay. Well, during this time, I've not
been, you know, doing these programs
with you live. I've been doing a lot of
research. Okay. And so, probably about a
half a dozen things are coming out here
in the next couple of months to freak
everybody out.
Um the the one that I want to talk about
today is um dementia in the young
people. Okay. And um
dementia in young people is related of
course to um 15 factors. 15 factors. And
these were two studies. One was in um uh
let's see here England and the other one
was in the Netherlands. Okay. It was a
four-year study. They looked at 356,052
young people. Okay? And they found out
what is causing
dementia in young people. Okay? Um
number one is smoking. Okay? We can get
more into that in detail. I want to run
through and get all these in here.
Smoking was one. Uh low formal education
was another issue. Uh let's see here.
low social standing of the family. Okay.
Um number four um uh
let's see apop proteins okay
were missing out of their diet. Uh let's
see here. Abstinence from A1 cohorts.
Okay. Uh number six was alcohol use
disorder and they said a small amount of
alcohol was important.
Well, that's not true. Okay, but what do
people when they're drinking beer, what
do they do? They eat pecans and walnuts
and stuff like that. So, they're getting
some nutrition out of the nuts and
that's what they're missing when they
don't drink beer as a kid. They're just
not eating nuts. Okay. So, that was kind
of an interesting finding. Okay. Um,
social isolation. Um, vitamin D
deficiency.
I thought that was interesting. That was
the only nutrient they said was missing
was vitamin D. High levels of uh let's
see here. High levels of um
uh
oh C reactive proteins. Um that was
number nine. Number 10. Uh let's see
here.
Reduced hand grip strength.
Uh number 11.
Okay.
uh
>> health.
>> Dr. I know that's what those reports are
showing, but what do you
>> with all of your research knowledge and
something that they don't have is
education in nutrition? What do you see
as being risk factors and
>> risk factors? Okay. The risk factors
are misdirection by the medical system.
The medical system is making people go
the wrong direction. They say no
cholesterol. They give you cholesterol
lowering drugs. They tell you
cholesterol free diets. Um they have all
kinds of stuff about no cholesterol. No
cholesterol. No cholesterol. Well, when
you are missing something upstairs and
you're not social, uh you can't function
properly in a group, which is humans are
groupies. Okay? So, when you can't
function in a group, there's something
missing here. Well, cholesterol
deficiency is a problem.
Cholesterol deficiency is a problem.
Just the opposite of what doctors say.
Myelin is made of lipids and proteins, a
fatty substance with a whitish
appearance. The uh let's see here the
lipid composition of myelin. Okay, lipid
composition of myelin um
is the sheath is made up of high amounts
of cholesterol. Milin cannot be
synthesized without cholesterol and
cholesterol
um availability goes to the liver and
liver converts the cholesterol to
myelin. Okay, that's how that all
happens. And so limit, you know, so when
people are drinking beer and they're and
they're having these walnuts and pecans
and stuff like that, they're getting
they eat they eat um all kinds of soups
and and stuff like that with beans in
it. Okay, chili with beans in it.
They're getting these nutrients, these
raw materials that the liver makes
cholesterol from. That's the connection.
Okay. Myelin cannot be synthesized
without cholesterol. And cholesterol
availability is a critical it's in big
big print critical prerequisite and a
limiting factor of myelin membrane
growth and production and maintenance.
Okay. And so let's see here.
Additional cholesterol effects. It aids
in production of sex hormones. But 95%
of sex hormones are made from
cholesterol. Okay. It's a building block
for human tissues including the brain
and spinal cord and and major nerves
like you know milein ner and the big
nerves. Okay. Assist in bowel production
of the liver and pain. Um
disease is any condition that causes the
damage protective covering of myelin and
the brain and spinal cord depending on
the location. It's not the same for the
whole brain and the length of the spinal
cord, but it varies from 35% to 80% um
is
myelin. Okay. And when myelin sheath is
damaged, nerve impulses are slow or even
stop causing neurological problems
including social behavior problems. Uh
demalination associated diseases. We're
looking at Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson's disease, multiple scerosis,
amotrophic lateroscerosis, Huntington's
Korea, frontal temporal dementia, which
is kind of a new division of the
mzheimer's disease, Bell's palsy,
cervical spinalosis, optic neuritis,
pariccom tooth, dam syndrome. You've
heard of all these things, right?
um
myelin, oligodendrite, glyoprotein
antibbody associated diseases, um
transverse myelitis, disseminated
encphylphopathy,
chronic inflammatory demalinating,
polyurop neuropathies and I could go on
because you know there's about a hundred
of these problems that are cholesterol
deficiencies
and doctors just want to give you
cortisone,
okay, and B vitamin injections and that
kind of
uh vision loss, muscle weakness, muscle
stiffness, loss of coordination, walking
problems, change in sensations,
changes in bladder and bowel function,
nerve pain, overall fatigue,
uncontrolled body, these are all
deficiencies of myelin.
Okay. And of course Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson's disease, multiple scerosis,
atrophic material sclerosis,
Huntington's Korea, front of temporal
dementia which is kind of a new division
of Alzheimer's disease. It just affects
the front of the brain and the sides in
the temples instead of the entire brain,
charcoal marie tooth, bell pulsey,
cervical spinalis, carpal tunnel
syndrome, um
hereditary neuropathies,
pressure pulsies, myopathys, optic
neuropathies. Optimopathies are very
common because when you have
osteoporosis of the skull which usually
also goes along with this it's two
different problems but they go along
together sometimes you have osteoporosis
you get a squeezing okay of the 12 pairs
of cranial nerve in the spinal cord and
that's why we came out had one guy today
buy a hundred of these okay it's all in
your head and there's a CD that goes
along with it now the CD there you go um
covers primarily the spinal cord
And the book that's all in your head
covers the 12 pairs of cranial nerves.
These are indispensable tools, okay, to
help your family deal with things so you
don't have to deal with the problems.
You can prevent these problems. They're
not genetic. And medical doctors will
tell you that these things tend to run
in the families. So they believe it's
genetic. Well, it runs in the families
because everybody's eating the same way.
It's just that simple. Okay. So,
um, what I want everybody to do is kind
of get these tools and that includes Dr.
Wallock's 90 for life crusade to save
humanity and the world is as as a flip
chart. And in here, we've got about a
dozen famous people who came to us with
terrible, terrible diseases that the
doctors couldn't fix. They were just
giving them cortisone and stuff like
that. And we have their pictures. We
have their stories. Many of them have
pictures of they and I together because
um uh we actually saved them. We saved
them with Dr. Wallik's 90 for life
crusade to save humanity in the world.
And so they allowed us to use their
their images. Pat Boon, Danny Glover,
uh Jesse Medelis, uh Crelo Dollar, Dr.
Michael Free Freeman, that's a big story
there. uh Theo Ratliff, Mike Glenn,
Martin Luther King III, Andy Young,
Kelly Herren, Becca Dukes,
okay, a director of student services,
uh, Institute of Holistic Health. So, we
really appreciate um all those
information people are dealing with. we
can eliminate these diseases like in I
always say give me 90 days usually
within two to six weeks you see
significant improvement
um that's that the story
um with um Pastor Mike Freeman that's
one of my favorites okay he was in a
coma in a hospital up in Maryland and
the doctors were just giving him
cortisone and stuff like that um and he
was slowly getting worse and He got to
the point where they the doctors called
the family said, "Look, we we pulled the
IVs on him. He only has either hours or
days to live. Better come say your
goodbyes if you're going to see him.
He's still unconscious, but you'll at
least have the pleasure of knowing you
said goodbye to him while he's still
alive." Okay. And so, um, let's see
here. Linda Tyler, one of his church
members, one of our great distributors
up there from Maryland, calls me and
says, "Hey, is there anything we can do
for him?" And she reminds me of the
story. I said, "Yeah, let's just get the
plant minerals." She said, "Well, I've
got three bottles of it in the my car
right now." I said, "Go get them. I want
you to rub half a teacup on his chest,
his upper belly, lower belly, and his
upper back between his shoulder blades
and his lower back and lower lower back
three times a day. Okay? Do that
faithfully." She said she would do it.
Well, she calls me the next day and
says, "Guess what? Pastor Mike, who's
been in a coma for three and a half
months, got up, shaved, and he's ready
to go just by he absorbed the minerals."
He was missing those minerals because
they were giving him stuff through his
IVs and this and the other that had
gluten in it and he couldn't absorb any
nutrition from any direction. Okay? And
so that's that was a a a great story. We
have a CD that tells the story.
Okay. And um it just it blows your mind.
Okay. Uh and we have the books. Let's
see. The Wall Revolution. We have
epigenetics.
There are no genetically transmitted
diseases.
diseases. There are no genly transmitted
diseases. There. There you go.
Epigenetics. And I'm considered one of
the founding fathers of it because we
had all these diseases that were
supposed to be genetic and all these
famous people that were registered and
and all the genetics people were running
around telling about how these people
have these gene problems and we reversed
them with just um our supplement
program, the 90s essential nutrients
plus the secret sauces for those
particular diseases. And um so we have
the cost is staggering.
Okay, the cost is staggering. what we
spend to deal with these diseases.
Alzheimer's disease, each year in
America alone, just to treat the
symptoms, not to prevent or cure it.
Just to treat the symptoms, $345
billion a year. Arthritis, just to treat
the symptoms, not to prevent or cure it
in America alone each year, $626.8
billion. Diabetes, not to not to prevent
it or cure it, but just to treat the
symptoms, $342 billion. Heart disease,
not to prevent it or cure it, but just
to treat the symptoms, 316.8 8 billion.
Obesity, $260 billion. It goes on and on
and on. And so then my next favorite one
out of all that, it goes
to osteoporosis
and it comes down to,
let me get the right piece of paper
here. It comes down to I think it's like
10 trillion.
Oh, $6.5 trillion. 6.5 trillion with a T
dollars each year spent between three
communities the United States, Canada
and EU just to treat the symptoms of
osteoporosis because most people think
osteoporosis is a disease of aging. No,
it's a very simple nutritional deficient
disease and if you take your 90
essential nutrients and stay away from
all the bad foods um you will get rid of
osteoporosis. I don't care if you've had
it for 25 years it still goes away. Give
me 90 days. That's why I say you know 90
for life crusade. you give me 90 days.
In almost all instances, we can reverse
these issues. Okay? We can reverse these
issues. And so, uh, we had, you know, a
guy today a 100 copies of the book,
um, dead.
>> It's all in your head.
>> Oh,
>> was it It's all in your head that he did
the 100 copies of.
>> No. Well, actually, um, we sell 100
copies a lot of times. This one today
was Dead Doctors Don't Lie. It was
actually the uh videos of Dead Doctors
Don't Lie. He bought a 100 copies of
that. Okay? Because he is saying, "I'm
tired of seeing all this stuff. Let's
get rid of it." And so he's ready to go
to work. We have the tools. We have 23
uh really critical first level
information books that the information
was never published in this fashion
before. 23. Um, Rebecca are working on a
couple more here real quick.
>> 24, doc. The flip chart makes 24.
>> Oh, that's right. Flip chart makes 24.
Thank you. Okay. So, this is one of
those things where just just
osteoporosis of the skull, loss of the
sense of smell, optic nerve neuropathy,
number two, um loss of smells, number
one,tosis,
pupil can't respond to light, cranial
nerve number three, double vision,
pulsey. Okay. Cranial nerve number four.
Cranial nerve number five, trigeminal.
Very painful. Cranial nerve number six
being squeezed by osteopro skull. Double
vision, stbismas, bell's pulsy. Um the
seventh cranial nerve, your face droops,
tenitis, ringing in the ear, deafness,
vertigo, miners disease, eighth cranial
nerve being squeezed, loss of gag reflex
and taste. Cranial nerve number nine,
cranial nerve number 10, gastropesis,
COPD and hiccups. Okay. Cranial nerve
number 11, loss of trapezius and other
um
um nerves and muscles, you know, kind of
from the midchest up. Okay. And then
atrophy of the tongue and speech,
cranial nerve number 12. And um it's one
of those things where spinal cord um
problems. Okay. Herbs pulsey. It's one
of those things. Um it's also known as
Wix um fibrosis. Wix fibrosis. And so
don't forget the book and the CD. Okay.
Um it's all in your head. Oh my gosh.
You'll be amazed at how many disease you
can get rid of in weeks and months.
>> Well, Dr. Wick, we talked about
dementia. We talked about all of the
symptoms that are associated with
cholesterol deficiencies already today
on the program. We've also spoken of
osteoporosis of the skull. Folks, if
you've got osteoporosis or arthritis in
one part of your body, think about it.
How can it just be affecting that one
part? It's all over. All the cells of
the body are connected. What we put into
our mouth nourishes all the cells or
creates deficiencies because we're not
putting that nourishment in of the whole
entire body, not just one little
section. It just happens that that one
little section is where you're filling
it first or most.
So, we encourage you to give Dr.
Wallik's philosophy and his approach to
creating better health and wellness
minimum of 90 days. And then you want to
do the 90 essential nutrients for the
rest of your life because it's like
putting gas in a car.
If you don't put gas in your car and you
continue to run it, it's going to stop
on you. It's going to start breaking
down. Don't put the oil in. You don't
put the transmission fluid in. Don't put
the antifreeze in the windshield wiper
fluids. You know, that's just one of the
minor things.
Well, it comes down to the body has
major and minor things going on that
if we don't nourish it,
all those little things create big
problems, folks. And that's what this
program is all about is to help you not
have to go to those big problem issues
because of simple nutritional
deficiencies.
Yes, simple nutritional deficiencies.
So, Dr. Wallik has put together all of
his research and I was going to bring
out my big book and I forgot to have it
handy, Dr. walley which was you your
first publication or was that your
second publication the diseases of
exotic animals that is a national
treasure in the Smithsonian Institute?
>> Yeah, diseases of exotic animals. Uh
that was my I think my first book. Okay.
It was 10 years of autopsies and um you
know over 20,000 autopsies just in that
one study in 10 years and it was
published and uh it's it's shocked
everybody, okay, that the Smithsonian
Institute put it in as a national
treasure into their library. Oh my gosh,
we're so proud of that because how many
people have we saved? How many people
have we educated? Um, I'm so so so proud
of that book. Um, and of course it's one
of the first books that's talked about
in the slip chart that shows you a co
picture of the cover. It tells you about
the book and how it got put together and
everything like that. So
yeah, it's in the first part of the flip
chart.
>> Yep.
>> I know it's there, Doc. I put it there.
Oh, folks, you can go to drjwwallik.com.
You will find all of Dr. Wallak's
publications and not only just books,
but also CDs, DVDs, and information,
more information about him. And Dr. Wik,
we have hands that are up. We have
questions that are up. The first one
that I want to address is um Rohiwa in
South Africa is asking which book
contains the food list per condition.
And
so I know Dead Doctors Don't Lie speaks
of that. Um let's play doctor speaks of
that.
>> I'm sorry I missed that. What what
health problem does she have?
So the book she's wanting to know which
book lists foods or it would actually be
nutrition that's causing the deficiency
or what you would add to the diet if you
have these different symptoms.
>> So what would be your first book that
you would recommend?
>> Well, there's three of them. Okay. One
is of course um Dead Doctors Don't Lie.
Another one is Epigenetics.
and then the wall revolution. Then the
number four would be the flip chart. Now
this book, the diseases of exotic
animals is in the Smithsonian Institute
is on page seven of the flip chart. It's
the first book listed, disease of exotic
animals. Oh my gosh. Okay.
>> All right.
>> It only has a small paragraph. Let me
read this. It says, "Dr. Dr. Wall's
thesis is considered a national treasure
and the original is held in the
Smithsonian Institute Washington DC.
It's Dr. Wallock's wish that the book
his book provide a widespread
understanding of the anatomy,
physiology, diagnosis and treatment of
the rainbow of species with which we
share this planet then and now. And of
course, this is one of those things
where
the title of the book is diseases of
exotic animals medical and surgical
management.
And it just blows everybody's mind when
they read this. What mean giraffe
have licorosis? You mean uh tortoises
have lung disease? You know, people
don't think about that. Okay. And so
this was really a scientific
breakthrough of magnitude
proportions.
>> Okay. Very very proud of that. Page
seven of the flip chart.
And one more folks, dolphins have
congestive heart failure.
What do you remember about that story,
Doc?
>> With a congestive heart failure, which
then created a product called destress.
>> Yeah. Well, the dolphins, you know, they
had the the shows at the various zoos
and aquariums and things like that, and
they were dying. And they were dying
because they were getting fish. Okay.
that actually had enzymes in the fish's
tissues that killed the the the vitamins
that they were missing. They wound up
with congestive heart failure. And
that's why we came out with our
um wonderful product, the D-Stress.
Okay, the D-stress product is actually
designed to prevent and reverse
congestive heart failure
that was designed for the dolphins
>> and that's added to a solid foundation
of the 90 essential nutrients.
>> That's correct. That that particular
nutrient is in the 90 and of course we
have the bottles. I take three of those
twice a day and you know I'm 84 going on
85 here and I don't have any heart
issues. Never had any heart issues.
Okay. And I I played all kinds of
sports. I was in the military. Um and so
it's one of those things where if I
could have had
heart issue, I'd have got a heart issue.
But I I was taking all these nutrients
that I had um fallen in love with and
all these nutrients. It just made sense.
we were giving them. That's how I found
the cause preventing cure for mustard.
Okay? Was we had mustard in animals and
we gave them these nutrients and so I
just started giving it to kids, Jerry's
kids and we started curing these kids
with mus. They had it for 10 years, 20
years and in a month it would go away.
>> Wow. Well, Dr. Wick, we have some
testimonials here out on YouTube as
well. So Joe is saying, "My vision is
getting back to normal." Thanks, doc.
Thought I may have needed laser eye
surgery to correct it and can't afford
that. So, that is wonderful, Joe. So
excited to hear that as well. Um, and
there's many, many more. So, Dr. Wick,
let's get to some of the questions that
are coming up. And the first one is
Josie. Chelsea is uh writing a question
in regards to her mother who is on a
blood thinner and would like to know
what they can do. So blood thinner dirty
blood
what what would be the cause of dirty
blood and what can we do? And if Josie's
I don't have weight um or age, but if
she's on a blood thinner, she's say
she's 90 years old and 100 pounds.
>> Okay.
>> It's not too late, is it?
>> No, of course not. Um she could be 120
or more. Okay. And so it's one of those
things where got to get rid of all the
bad foods. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no glutens, no
buckwheat, uh no sugar, no carbonated
drinks. Even the diet one's got to go.
And then she weighs 90 pounds or 100
pounds, whatever it is. She can have one
healthy brain and heart pack, a half a
dose of everything I think twice a day.
And then let's see her uh her big
question was what what was this thing
that was popping up on her now?
>> So she's on a blood thinner.
>> Okay. Because they're afraid of blood
clots
>> pro possibly.
>> Okay. So what we wanted to have is the
ultra daily classic tablets. Okay. She
go ahead and she can take uh two of
those twice a day. So, one bottle a
month will last her. Um that's in
addition to one healthy brain and heart
pack. A half a dose of everything twice
a day. Okay. And then I would give her
the ultimate daily classic tablets. Give
her two of those twice a day or two,
three times a day. And um it will
rebuild the heart and support the kidney
function, blood pressure, blood flow
through blocked arteries. It's really a
great product. I I take three of those
twice a day.
>> Awesome. Thank you so much, Dr. Wallik.
And let's go over to
um I have one more question here. And
this is something that Dr. Wallick just
in the last two years you have added
buckwheat to the bad foods list. So,
let's address that. I know that at one
time because buckwheat is considered
gluten-free,
it was on that good foods list, not on
the bad foods list. But you discovered
that it has a chemical that is a
phototoxin
that is adding it to the bad foods list
and that being faggoyne. So buckwheat,
Dr. Wallick.
>> Yeah, it's you got exactly right.
fagopyines in the buckwheat actually um
prevents you from absorbing and
utilizing nutrients. So it's just as bad
as I think it's worse than gluten
because most people have heard that
gluten is bad for you. But everybody
think well buckwheat pancakes, buckwheat
this, buckwheat that. Um and so uh I
know our family we would eat buckwheat
pancakes you know on Sunday after church
kind of thing. Um um but that was only
once a week. We didn't eat it once a day
or twice a day. We didn't have any
buckwheat bread or anything like that,
but we did have the pancakes once a
week. And it's a miracle we all didn't
die.
>> And and that chemical, it damages the
villi. Is that what the the problem is?
>> Yes.
>> All right. And and folks, for you those
of you who don't know what the villi is,
is that's like fingers. that looks like
fingers inside the intestines like a
shag rug. And when you have that
damaged, then you don't have all of that
surface to absorb the nutrients as
they're going through the digestive
system.
>> Then your intestines look like a plastic
tube. Then your intestines look like a
plastic tube. You lose 90% of the
surface area.
>> And and that's what gluten does as well.
And I promised Dr. Wall that I would
have a picture to show, but I
don't have it. I'm sorry, Doc. I failed
you on that one,
>> but we'll have it again soon. So,
confused. I hope that um helps to bring
a little light on that that at one time,
yes, it was on the good foods list. So,
that what you saw has been or is
outdated.
Next, let's go to Marilyn who has her
hand up patiently.
And let me find you, Marilyn. Where did
you go?
Marilyn, if you can add yourself to the
screen since you are a co-host, that
would be fantastic. There you are.
There.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Marilyn, what questions do
you have for us today?
>> Okay. We have the product Herbal
Rainforest, and it always talks about
detoxification.
Does that mean it's just removing heavy
metals? What's all involved in the
detoxification?
>> Okay. It it'll rem remove healthy
metals. It'll re it will um excuse me
unhealthy metals. It'll reduce um the
various
um herbs that are bad. It'll re it'll
reduce overdoses of like antibiotics.
I like herbal rainforest when somebody
has an overdose of anything because it
will get rid of the overdose.
>> And how often should we be taking it?
Um, if you have a problem, I would start
out at two or three times a day
depending on your body weight. Uh, if
you don't have a problem, you could take
it, you know, maybe twice a week or
something like that. You don't have to
go crazy on it if you don't have a
problem.
>> So, it's not like we should take it like
every three months or
we can take it that that often.
>> Well, here here's what you want to do.
Of course, you're going to be taking a
blood test. You know, they uh once every
month or a couple of months. You also
want to get a hair analysis once every
couple of months or is three months at
least a hair analysis and that will give
you um a
recorded scientifically collected
information as to whether or not you
need this stuff. Okay? There's no sense
to run up a bill of 700 bucks because
you're buying 20 different products
because somebody says take this, another
person said take that. Another one says
take this and you're taking 700 bucks
worth of products and you only probably
need the 90 essential nutrients. And so
this is why I like the herbal rainforest
because it's a detoxifier of anything
that's sort of high. And so it's it's
what it's designed to do. It has I think
a dozen different herbs in it. Okay.
>> Yes.
mechanicals too. Okay. Thank you. I
appreciate that.
>> Is that your only question?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Thank you so much, Marilyn. And
let's go to the next hand that is up.
Dr. Wallik and Rosemary, go ahead and
unmute yourself.
>> Good day, everybody.
>> Hi.
>> Um, hello.
>> I need to ask about one of my clients.
She had breast implants that leaked and
then she had them removed. And they told
her to go to get a mammogram and she
did. And the mammogram told her that the
the leaked part of her implants were
attached to her lymph nodes under her
arm. And she came to me as a lymph
therapist to do a lymph on her. And I
told her I couldn't do that until I
checked it out to make sure I wouldn't
do her harm.
>> Well, she'd be a perfect one. She'd be a
perfect one for the, you know, don't
forget the 90 essential nutrients and
the the herbal rainforest. That would be
a perfect one for her.
>> I've tried to talk to her, but she
thinks she knows more than I do.
>> Okay. Well, you know, we do our best and
you know, even God doesn't have
everybody listen to him, so I don't feel
bad about that.
>> But would I do would would I do her any
harm if I did a lint therapy on her?
>> Yes.
>> I'm sorry if you did what? Would I do
her any harm if I did a lymph on her?
I'm concerned about moving that material
around.
>> Well, you don't want to be moving that
material around. You want to get it out
of there.
>> You want to go one direction is to go to
the to the kidneys and so they can pee
them out.
>> So, Dr. Wall, it sounds like rosemary is
um like does a lot of massage where you
can do massage up the lymph to help
clear the stuff that's plugged in the
lymph.
Clearing that out is what we're
ultimately trying to do, right?
>> That's correct.
>> It didn't say it was in the lymph. It
was on the lymph lymph on the lymph
nodes
under her arm.
>> So, it's on the surface of the lymph
nodes.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. I I'd go, you know, with the 90s
essential nutrients, get rid of the bad
food, and then do the um uh
>> rainforest.
>> Yeah. The the rainforest, urbal
rainforest. And um that that's the sort
of thing it was built for.
>> Okay, I will tell her that. Thank you.
>> You bet.
>> Thank you, Rosemary. And folks,
the body can do some amazing things when
it comes to
all the cells of the body, but it has to
have those raw ingredients in order to
rebuild the way it was designed to. So
whether it's clearing stuff up, whether
it's building muscle, whether it's
clearing the toxins out, it still needs
those 90 essential nutrients to be able
to do it efficiently and more
thoroughly.
So TC,
go ahead and unmute yourself.
What question do you have for Dr. Wallik
today?
>> Um, I talked to you back in uh
September. you uh gave me a regimen to
do for my hernia. I don't know if you
remember. Uh
>> I apologize. I've talked to a thousand
people since then.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Well, anyways, I I
started doing it, but I was uh uh trying
to take it slow with small doses. One
thing is I noticed when I took u uh for
my third meal with the MSM and the uh uh
Ultimate Daily Classic tablet, I was
getting some side effects. So, I stopped
taking it and then I was having some
withdrawal symptoms for about nine days
and then I went to see my doctor to see
if it would be okay for me to take them.
He said I showed him all the
supplements. He said, "They're okay to
take. Uh there's no problem. Won't do
you any harm. Won't hurt you to take
them." U he didn't think though I should
take the fish oil because I uh I'm thin
and he said I could cause bleeding. But
anyways, long story short, I'll tell
you. I started the uh the regimen
actually at the beginning of November. I
wanted to call you, but you hadn't been
on for a while to let you know what I
was doing. But I've been taking uh the
uh the collagen, the hair, skin, and
nail support. I take that for the third
meal, but uh that's the only thing I
take for the third meal. And for the
first couple of months, I was taking the
MSM. I was taking three capsules twice a
day, the uh hair, skin, and nail
support, two capsules twice a day. But
for the last couple of weeks, I upped it
to four MSMs twice a day and three hair,
skin, and nail
uh twice a day. So, I'm taking the full
amount of collagen and the MSM and the
uh hair, skin, and nail. The uh Ultimate
Daily Classic tablet, uh you mentioned
that I could cut it in half. So, I take
either a half a tablet twice a day or I
actually take like one whole one and
then a half of one.
>> Wait a minute. How much do you weigh?
>> Uh, I'm uh Well, I was 150 and I I I
actually lost some weight with this was
down to 142.
>> About 144.
>> Yeah, I would go I would go with two of
those Ultra Daily Classic tablets twice
a day, not a half of one twice a day.
>> Okay. Well, uh, when I was doing this, I
I was doing a whole tablet.
I did that for a whole week uh for each
meal or a couple meals anyways. And when
I was working out and I was doing uh uh
bicep curls, I was getting a a pain in
my left elbow crease, you know, where
they draw blood from there, but I hadn't
had blood drawn there for two years, but
I was getting some pain in that.
>> Okay, stop there for a minute. Stop
there for a minute. You're taking any
gluccoel or collagen peptides or
anything like that to rebuild cartilage
and ligaments and tendons and connective
tissue? I do take the collagen peptides.
Yeah, I take a full scoop of that. I
take the regular one, full scoop of that
twice a day. And then I take the uh
hair, skin, and nail support, a full
scoop of that for my third meal.
>> So, I'm getting three of those a day.
>> Okay? Just just remember, you got to
stay away from the bad foods. That's
just as important as taking the
supplements because the bad foods block
uh a lot of the effectiveness of the
good foods and the supplements. And so
it's important that everybody in the
household is also free of all the bad
stuff so you're not getting
crosscontaminated in the laundry and the
couch and the bed and the rugs and
chairs and so forth. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Well, my question though, I guess at
this point is that I also was uh taking
the uh you said to take two brain and
heart packs, but because of my weight, I
was taking one and a half, but with the
EFAs, I wasn't really taking those
because my doctor said about the fish
oil, but I do eat fish and I eat u nuts
and seeds and I figured that I was
probably getting enough EFAs
a person of 80 pound body weight.
>> Stop. Stop.
>> Do you put oil in your car? You put dirt
from Texas in your car.
>> Uh,
>> come on. There's bound to be some oil in
that dirt from Texas. Why don't you just
put dirt from Texas in there instead of
a can of oil?
>> Okay.
>> You got to do the same thing for
yourself. You want to get those
those nutrients that are necessary. When
you have a when you have a pathology,
you need to ramp up on those nutrients.
They're
okay. And um
uh you know what can I say? You need to
be a little more heavy-handed
to deal with these things.
>> So Dr. Wallik, one of the things that he
mentioned is his doctor told him not to
take EFAs. Is that a wise choice? It's
not a wise choice because EFAs prevent
um things like strokes, blood clots, um
helps helps you um with all your every
cell wall in the body requires that
>> would you concur or differ that some
people should not take uh fish oil
because of it could cause bleeding?
Because I'll tell you, I was what I did
a couple weeks ago. So, I did buy the
EFAs and then I started taking them and
then I started noticing that I was
getting I could feel the dilation take
place and I was getting uh in my right
arm I noticed I was getting some uh I
could see the veins under the arm and I
was getting a couple of blood blisters.
>> So, I'm thinking maybe I shouldn't take
that full amount of those EFAs.
>> Well, just just cut it in half for a
while.
>> Okay. I I can take I can take
>> the FAS the FAS are essential for the
cell walls of every cell in your body.
>> Okay?
>> It's also necessary for hormones. It's
also necessary for skin health. And so
to
eliminate EFAs because some doctor has
some sort of strange dissatisfaction
with it. Um is like saying no oxygen,
you can rust. Don't take any oxygen. You
can rust. Okay. That would be very
stupid.
>> Okay. Now, I also noticed with the
selenium, I I misread the label. I
thought it said take one a day. They
actually say to take three a day.
>> That's correct. I take three twice a
day. I only weigh 142 pounds.
>> Okay. So, I was only taking like one or
two a day. Uh
>> you're under you're way underdosing.
>> Okay. Uh and I
>> give us a call in a couple weeks. We got
a bunch of other callers here. We got to
run
>> and unfortunately Dr. Wallik has to get
going as well. But TC as far
As far as what's on the label, um we
apologize. The FDA tells us what we can
and can't put on there and what's the
max that we can put on there. And
there's a lot of people that have been
killed because of the FDA and their
recommendations. So, we definitely Dr.
Wallik has done a lot of research into
this and we've helped a lot of people
with his recommendations. Dr. Dr.
Wallik, we have time for one more
question and Roofia, go ahead and unmute
yourself.
>> All right. Uh, good evening everyone.
Uh, so I'm going to be quick for the
sake of time. H Dr. Wes, you have
assisted my do my daughter. I think it
was in September. So she was diagnosed
with a type 1 diabetes which you then
converted into um type two. So, but now
we've been following like a like a diet
for her and then it's been five days now
without us giving her insulin. So, we
are currently not administering any
insulin. It's been 5 days now.
>> So, but stop stop for a minute. Okay.
Rebecca, did you understand any of that?
>> Yes, I did. She's giving a testimony.
Her daughter started the program back in
September. She had been diagnosed as a
type 1 diabetic and then it was
downgraded to a type two diabetic and
now she's been five days without
requiring any insulin. Dr. Wallik.
>> Oh,
>> but she has a she has a question that
she'd like to pose to you now as well.
>> Okay.
>> So, that's that's fantastic. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. So like my question is uh since
we're not administering any insulin,
we've noted that especially in the
mornings when she wakes up her blood
sugar is um usually low like it ranges
between 3.7 and 3.3 and it only happens
in the morning and then she also
complains about uh the tummy cramps in
the morning and then uh just to add
another question on that so that we can
just answer everything at once. So, I
just wanted to find out with your
experience, how long does it take for
the pancreas to be like fully restored?
>> Okay. What was her question?
>> How long does it take for the pancreas
to be fully restored? Because right now
her blood sugar in the morning is is
low. Um, in Africa they use a different
metric or a different measurement system
than we do in the US, but her blood
sugar is low and she's having tummy
cramps in the area of the pancreas. So,
she wants to know about
>> Okay. Well, she's got to do the 90
essential nutrients. She got to do the
90. She can't just take one nutrient.
She got to take 90 essential nutrients.
Okay. The healthy brain and heart pack,
one per 100 pounds of body weight. And
then um she needs the um again I would
go with the sweeties and I would start
out with one sweeties a day um and you
know when she wakes up in the morning
with with breakfast and see how the
blood sugar goes. And um the we we see
people who were told they were type 1
diabetics and we were able to reverse it
because it really was a type two
diabetic. Type 1 diabetics is a birth
effect, not genetic, but the mother was
missing stuff when the pancreas was
forming and they didn't make enough
cells to make insulin. So, it's a birth
effect based on a nutritional deficiency
early in pregnancy. Okay, that's type 1
diabetes. Type two diabetes is always a
nutritional deficiency. You're eating
gluten and you can't absorb the
nutrients or um you're missing the
nutrients that are necessary for the um
for the um pancers to utilize the
nutrients properly. People say, "Which
nutrient is it?" Which Well, no, you got
to use them all. If I just say use one,
you'll use that one and you'll be you'll
be 89 short.
>> So, in this case, Dr. Wallock, she is
using the 90 essential nutrients. She is
also taking the sweeties, but what she
what can she do to help um lessen
prevent those tummy cramps that she's
experiencing in the morning?
>> Okay, she has tummy cramps. I'd go with
the ultimate enzymes. Take a couple of
those. say 10 minutes before breakfast,
10 minutes for lunch, 10 minutes for
dinner time. Would also have her take
more calcium,
okay? And then it wouldn't hurt for her
to take, okay, our collagen peptides,
okay, our collagen peptides.
Okay. Or pollen burst. Okay. It's called
pollen burst.
>> So, the liver formula, you're thinking
of the pollen burst liver formula.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that correct?
>> Yeah. Palm burst. It's a little bitty
pills about a quarter inch in diameter.
their flat disc, okay? And they have um
let's see here. They have the this
wonderful stuff, okay, called
glutathione,
okay? Great stuff for um supporting all
kinds of things that the body does to
make and wouldn't hurt also to uh in
addition to that. Um
gosh, oh, I would throw in the I26. So
all the mile myelin in the brain and the
spinal cord can work
>> which it also is very beneficial for the
digestive system everybody and Dr.
Wallik I have to kick you out so I don't
get fired but thank you so much for
being here with us and we will see you
again tomorrow
folks Thursday January 11th Dr. Wallik
will be on with us again and for those
of you who are watching TV yeah the
date doesn't matter because this
information is relevant all your year
long 247,
7 days a week. And that's just a little
plug for being able to find us in the
very near future, hopefully by the end
of this week on Apple TV, Roku TV, and
also Fire TV. you just look for Daily
with Doc. So folks, I just want to thank
you so much for being here with us. I
know there were some questions that we
did not get to. Um, go to our website
dailywithdoc.com.
Submit your questions there and we will
get answers to you and also to help
promote the show and we want to thank
you all for being here and watching.
Help others find it as well. And to
thank you for doing that, we do have a
giveaway that is going on. Go to
dwdgiveaway.com
and share our information on the
different social media platforms that
you participate in. So that's
dwdgiveaway.com.
And if I could get my co-hosts up on the
screen with me, I would greatly
appreciate being able to give them a
huge shout out. as we have Sherry here
with us that is help that who is helping
us get the show broadcasted out onto
those platforms and we have Phyllis who
is out there on those platforms bringing
in the questions and fielding questions
for us and also putting information in
the chat. We have Albert who is letting
people into the Zoom room, keeping an
eye on the chat and the cameras and
making sure that everybody's able to
have a safe place to be in order to get
this information. If you're here live
with us, we have Marilyn who does
amazing dictation and repeating what Dr.
Wallik says, the questions and
rephrasing them, which I saw Phyllis was
doing that as well. Um, so thank you
Marilyn for doing that. And we have AJ
who is kind of my technical advisor and
helping us get all of these uh platforms
rolling and especially the TV which we
are very very excited about. So thank
you all of you and all of the coaches
who join us. There are many of them that
are not on the screen who are here with
us. Whether you're in the Zoom room and
I saw some of them here with us today
and also out on YouTube and Rumble,
share this information with your folks,
folks.
And if somebody shared this information
with you, make sure that you get back
with them and ask them how you also can
choose this better health journey. My
name is Becca Dukes.
AJ, what am I forgetting?
Oh, something that I need. Okay, more
sleep, folks. And I love the fact that
we have a sleep bundle that offers
this information. Stop making faces, AJ.
that offers these products to you to
help you find better sleep as well. And
to make it easy for you, because I'm
doing this, too, go to
sleepwithbecka.com
and it will take you right to the page
that offers the sleep bundle. So again,
that's sleepwithbecca.com
and let's together get better sleep. So
until next time,
bye for now.
[Music]